in your study of physics you will often
encounter the idea of mass and you will
also might encounter the idea of inertia
and what i want to do in this video is
think about what is the similarity or
the difference between these two
concepts or these two ideas in physics
and i'm going to give you a little bit
of time to do it i encourage you to ask
people and search the web and look at
textbooks whatever you can do to figure
out the similarities and differences
between mass and inertia
so from a historic perspective if you
have asked for someone what does mass
mean or what does it represent they'll
say it means or it represents how much
stuff an object is made up of or how
much matter how much matter actually
constitutes an object
and if you were to ask them well what is
inertia then they'll say well inertia
describes an inertia is a property of an
object it's really how hard is it to
accelerate that object how hard is it to
change that object's velocity so we
could call this maybe resistance
resistance to
acceleration so on this first this first
glance right over here you might say
okay well these are two different ideas
and they seem like two different ideas
until we start thinking about a couple
of things one newton's second law and
also how you would actually go about
measuring mass so how would you actually
measure this right over here how would
you
measure mass because you might say well
maybe you just look at the size of the
object but the size by itself doesn't
tell you how much stuff there is you
could have a very large object that's
not very dense let's say cotton candy or
a hot air balloon and you could have a
very small object that's very very dense
you could take a a lead weight or
something even denser a teaspoon of the
material from a neutron star incredibly
incredibly dense very very high mass you
couldn't just look at the the size or
the volume of an object but lucky for us
newton's second law does give us a tool
for figuring out the mass of an object
newton's second law tells us that the
force that acts on an object is equal to
the mass of that object times the
acceleration
of that object and the acceleration and
the force are going to go in the exact
same direction or if you want to think
only about the magnitudes you could say
the magnitude of the force on a on a on
a object is going to be equal to its
mass
its mass
its mass times the magnitude of the
acceleration
you say well how does this allow me to
measure an object's mass well i can
apply some force to it i can apply some
force a certain magnitude and then i can
measure how much that object is
accelerated and then i could just solve
for m you divide both sides of this
equation by a you get f
over a is equal to m but what am i
measuring so i will actually solve for a
mass here i could you know i'll get my
proper units of mass depending on what
my units of force and acceleration are
right over here but what am i implicitly
measuring as well well i'm applying a
force on some something and i'm seeing
how much it's accelerating i'm seeing
what is its resistance to accelerating
so i'm really trying to also determine
its inertia so when you think about mass
in this way we now think about this as
actually inertial mass
inertial
inertial
mass one way to think about is that the
mass is actually quantifying that
object's inertia so we can split hairs
over the definitions but in this way of
viewing mass mass and inertia are really
the same thing and it's actually very
hard to just directly measure how much
stuff or matter there is that's why i
put it in quotes right here
the more pure definition of what mass
even is is or one of the more pure
definitions of what mass even is is how
resistant is that object to acceleration
because especially once you start
getting into these subatomic domains the
quantum domains the the idea of how much
stuff there is starts to become very
abstract and all we can do is measure
how does how does that that entity or
that particle how does that respond to
force how resistant is that to
acceleration and that will and that is
essentially what we're describing is
mass or inertial mass but you might say
wait that's not the only way to measure
mass you have newton's law of
gravitation i could have some object
that has a known mass
so let's say this is some object with a
known mass let's call it m1 and let's
say that there's some other object with
an unknown mass let's call it m2 and
this is the mass that we are trying to
measure and we know that they're going
to exert they're going to they're going
to pull on each other newton's law of
gravitation and everything we're talking
here we're talking about classical
mechanics that's the world we're going
to deal with we're not going to talk
about we're not going to talk general
relativity or anything like that right
now
but we know if we know this mass and if
we know the distance between them
we know the distance between their
center of masses
so just like that and if we can measure
their respective poles on each other so
we know that if m2 is pulling on m1 with
some force so i'll draw that as a vector
like this m1 will pull on m2 with an
equal and opposite force so a force with
the same magnitude but just the opposite
direction and so we can measure what
that force is we get we know what m1 is
we know the distance between them and
from that we can figure out what m2
needs to be and from and when you
measure mass when you think about mass
in this way you're actually referring to
gravitational mass let me write it this
way this right over here is
gravitational
gravitational
gravitational mass
now lucky for us it has been verified
that these two things these two things
are actually measuring the exact same
thing the inertial mass is equivalent to
gravitational mass so you can debate on
the definitions and it might be a little
different in different contexts
sometimes people want you to think of
more in classical terms inertias
resistance to acceleration mass is how
much matter there is
but essentially they're talking about
the same thing
mass is a measure of how resistant
something is to acceleration or mass is
a measure of inertia